David you asked a very interesting
question because we live in the
so-called digital age everything is
digital digital TV digital information
and everything is digital it's the sexy
word of the day however as you pointed
out analog has actually more information
you lose information by going from
analog to digital so then the obvious
question is why bother if you lose
information going from analog to digital
then why bother to make this
multibillion-dollar conversion all our
equipment television radio being
converted from analog to digital
why well here's how it works an analog
signal is nothing but a squiggle with
lines can being can take any any number
between let's say 0 & 1
digital only breaks things up into zeros
and 1 and nothing in between so if I
take a curve like this and then break it
up into zeros and ones obviously I lose
information in the process so what do I
gain I've got to gain something back and
what I gain is enormous because once
everything is risu is reduced as zeros
and 1 zeros and ones it means I can copy
copy the original wave with no errors if
I have a wave like this and I ask you to
make a copy of it well it's quite
difficult
I get tracing paper I get a pencil and
paper and I try to trace it out and then
if you make a copy of a copy you lose
more information for example take a
Xerox and make a Xerox of a Xerox and
then make a Xerox of a Xerox of a cervix
after a while the paper becomes almost
white because each time you throw out
something you lose information but now
take 0 & 1 and make a copy you get 0 & 1
make another copy
you get zero in one make a billion
copies and you still get 0 & 1 not only
that you can also massage the signal you
can play with it accentuate things bring
out certain low frequencies high
frequencies you can play with it while
analog you lose information each
now think about it this interview here
is taking place in a studio where my
image is being transferred optically to
a silicon chip and then sent over the
web and then download it into your PC
how many reproductions took place I
don't know 10 15 reproductions if that
was an analog signal by the time you see
my image it'd be all blurry but
complements of digital you see it crisp
and sharp every single time so it answer
your question we do lose information
going from analog to digital but will be
gain is enormous the ability to copy
without error the ability to manipulate
and that's why we call it the digital
revolution